i wanted to ask you about working with
show runners and in particular the
differences between
some of the ones that you've worked with
i guess mainly like dan
matt liz and carly who does something
super unique on those sets that really
stands out to you as far as keeping
their overall vision for the show intact
oh this is a minefield um okay
well the first thing that needs to be
said as the umbrella statement
is glow is the first show i've been on
as
number one on the call sheet you know
essentially the lead of the show
and when that is your role i would say
that you have
one has a very different relationship
with their showrunners
so innately you know i'm
much closer with liz and carly i felt
like
you know i i feel like it's it's sort of
hard i mean they're all so distinct so
it's actually quite easy to compare
everybody but like
i had a much more personal relationship
with liz and carly because that's the
nature of
a number one in their show runners and i
think that is
has always been the case and i observed
it on those other shows you know with
joel mchale
and uh jon hamm but
you know matt weiner i think is
notorious
for being very specific
and deservedly so the dialogue
you know the writing on mad men was so
incredible
and talk about it being easy to memorize
because there's so much going on there's
so much subtext
written into every scene characters who
pop in for one scene have like a ton of
backstory
going on everything carries weight and
meaning so
he was you know a real stickler for us
saying everything
word perfect word for word um
you know sometimes even like gestures
were written
into the dialogue she puts her hand to
her forehead and you better put it to
your forehead
right then um so that was sort of a
different style of
kind of trying to go okay well let me
make this movement still seem organic
uh you know and it should because it
makes a lot of sense for what this
character
would do but i loved working for matt
because
i love working for someone who knows
exactly what they want and then you know
that you've got this like really
self-assured leader and when you've
hit it they tell you um
but matt especially in the first few
seasons too matt was on set
a ton like he he really was always right
there making sure that
every single piece was perfect
uh and then dan harmon's the opposite
where we wouldn't see him that much he
was often up in his office but he had a
feed
to watch us um so he would sometimes
text
us uh notes or
or uh you know things like that and dan
you know dan has got this crazy genius
mind i think it thrives more
in chaos and he he had a much different
battle
uh in terms of you know i think matt
having the first
scripted show for amc really ha got a
lot of
creative freedom versus dan harmon is
coming
to nbc who you know has been doing
sitcoms since the dawn of tv and dan's
trying to push against that and make it
something different so
there was a sense of procrastination
that i think came out of
him not wanting the network to have
control over what we were doing
you know so so it just everything felt a
little more uh
frantic frenetic chaotic you know there
were times where dan would come down and
we didn't really have all this
maybe we didn't have the scripts yet for
the whole episode
but we had some scenes and then dan
harmon would come and kind of give us
context and
be a little more physical and you know
it was like a little messier but it
really worked for the type of show
we were making and i think it gave all
of us room
also to bring our own things to those
roles and kind of really bond
as a cast and and become something else
and and liz and carly gosh i just
i adore those women i would say liz and
carly
brings so much compassion to everything
they do
and it certainly did feel different
having
that female energy having two women who
were really
in tune with every character and really
wanted to
talk to the actors about how they were
feeling about everything we deal with a
lot of tricky subject matters on glo
in terms of um you know very
sort of racist wrestling characters and
personas in the ring and also
you know to things like women in the
workplace and um abortion and
a lot of themes you know a lot of themes
of varying heaviness that we were
dealing with and
even in terms of like the nudity on the
show they always would
meet with women or at least phone call
beforehand to give you the context of
what the nudity was going to be on the
scene which was
i just think i've never seen it done
like that i've never experienced people
who were so
attentive and in touch with the entire
cast
in that way which was really lovely